STARTED WAY FOR- QUORUM TO BE
ESTABLISHED- WITH ONE OF THE
FIRST ADDRESS A LOGISTICAL
ITEMS FOR THIS POLICY HEARING
AND DUE TO COVER NINETEEN WE
CONTINUE TO PRACTICE PHYSICAL
TO SEE HERE IN THIS COMMITTEE
ROOM. AND THROUGHOUT THE
CAPITOL BUILDING A FOR THOSE
HERE IN ATTENDANCE THIS
AFTERNOON BOTH HEARING
PARTICIPANTS AND MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC PLEASE KNOW THAT
THROUGHOUT THIS HEARING. FACE
COVERAGE ARE REQUIRED TO BE ONE
AT ALL TIMES AND FIZZ AND I SIX
FEET OF PHYSICAL DISTANCE IT IS
EXPECTED TO BE MAINTAINED BY
ALL MEMBERS. OF THE PUBLIC- IF
YOU DO NOT HAVE A FACE COVERING
ONE WILL BE PROVIDED TO YOU-
AND DUE TO THESE PHYSICAL
DISEASE REQUIREMENTS WHEN FORCE
WE HAVE LIMITED SEATING
AVAILABLE- IN THIS ROOM AND WE
WILL BE CAREFULLY MANTRA
CAPACITY THROUGHOUT THE HEARING
THERE ARE SIX BILLS ON OUR
AGENDA. TO BE CONSIDERED BY
OUR- OUR COMMITTEE A TWO OF
WHICH ARE PROPOSED AS PART OF
OUR CONSENT CALENDAR AND FOR
EACH ITEM ON OUR AGENDA THERE
WILL BE AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT. COMMENTS MAY BE
MADE IN PERSON IN THIS ROOM BY
PHONE OR FROM A REMOTE
TESTIMONY STATION. OTHER MOTELS
MOST ISSUES ARE OUTSIDE OF THE
HEARING ROOM ON THE NORTH SIDE
OF THE CAPITOL THE STATIONS
AVAILABLE FOR PRIMARY WITNESSES
AS WELL AS FOR PUBLIC. COMMENT
THE PHONE NUMBER TO MAKE THE
PUBLIC COMMENTS WILL BE SHOWN
OR PROVIDED TO VIEWERS ON
SCREEN- THROUGHOUT THIS
HEARING- THE PHONE NUMBERS ALSO
POSTED ON OUR ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE WEBSITE FOR ALL THOSE
WHO WILL BE PROVIDING COMMENTS
TODAY WE ASK THAT YOU PLEASE.
STATE YOUR NAME AND IF
APPLICABLES THE ORGANIZATION
YOU REPRESENT AND IF YOU
SUPPORT OR OPPOSE THE BILL BE
CONSIDERED ANY MEMBER THE
PUBLIC IS ALSO WELCOME TO
SUBMIT WRITTEN COMMENTS TO OUR
COMMITTEE THROUGH EMAIL EMAILS
MAY BE SENT TO THE ADDRESS
FOUND. ON OUR WEBSITE WHICH IS.
A G. R. I. DOT COMMITTEE AT
ASSEMBLY DOT CA DOT GOP IN
ORDER TO FACILITATE THE GOAL OF
HUMAN AS MUCH FROM THE PUBLIC
WITHIN THE LIMITS OF OUR TIME
WE WILL NOT PERMIT- SOME
CONDUCT THAT DISRUPTS DISTURBS
OR OTHERWISE IMPEDES THE
ORDERLY CONDUCT OF OUR PROCEED
NOW PLEASE BE AWARE THAT
VIOLATIONS OF. THESE RULES MAY.
SUBJECT YOU TO RE MOVIL OR
OTHER FOR- PROCESS BY THIS
ASSEMBLY. AND SO WITH THAT- WE
WILL STILL WAIT TO ESTABLISH
QUORUM. AND WE WILL MOVE. TO
OUR FIRST- OR AFFORD TO FILE
ORDER THE FIRST BILL PROPOSED
ON ARTERIES AGENDA WHICH IS
SENATE BILL FIVE FOUR SEVEN-
CENTER GLAZER I DO NOT SEE
SENATOR GLAZERS OVERCOME
CONTACTED. END SCENE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER PATTERSON WHO WILL BE
PRESENTING FOR- SENATOR
FURTADO- WHICH IS FILE ITEM
NUMBER TWO SENATE BILL FOUR
FIVE THREE INVITE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER. PATTERSON TO THE PODIUM
TO PRESENT THE BILL. WELCOME
ASSEMBLY MEMBER. THE BAPTIST
CHURCH MEMBERS. PERCENT BILLS-
THE SUPPORT SUPPORT
RECOMMENDATIONS YES-
FOUR FIVE
THREE. DISCOVER VIRUSES
CIRCULATING IN THE ANIMAL
POPULATION. AT LEAST HALF OF
WHICH HAVE THE POTENTIAL TO
SPREAD TO HUMANS. UP THIS BILL
PUTS CALIFORNIA AT THE
FOREFRONT RESEARCHING ON
INFECTIOUS DISEASE AND
BIOSECURITY SB FIVE FOUR FIVE
THREE LAYS THE GROUNDWORK. TO
ENSURE BOTH OUR STATE IN THE
NATION ARE BETTER PREPARED FOR
THE NEXT GLOBAL PANDEMIC BY
ESTABLISHING A FUND TO SUPPORT
RESEARCH IN BIO SECURITY AND
EMERGING INFECTIOUS DISEASES.
AT THE JORDAN AGRICULTURAL
CENTER IN FRESNO THE BILL
ENSURES THE SENATE CAN RECEIVE
FEDERAL AND PRIVATE MONEY TO
SUPPORT THIS EFFORT- THE JORDAN
AGRICULTURE CENTER IS UNIQUELY
SUITED TO PURSUE THIS RESEARCH.
LOCATED IN THE HEART OF THE TOP
AGRICULTURAL REGION IN THE AREA-
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT WE HAVE
DR JASMEET BANS. HE IS A FAMILY
PHYSICIAN FROM BAKERSFIELD
CALIFORNIA AND DR STEPHAN HIGGS
DIRECTOR OF THE BIOSECURITY
RESEARCH INSTITUTE AT KANSAS
STATE. UNIVERSITY AND I THINK
THEY'RE BOTH ON THE TELEPHONE.
AND THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
AND I WANT TO. TURN OVER TO
SECRETARY REALLY QUICKLY TO
ESTABLISH COURT. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER REFRESH HERE MATHIS
WE'RE AGUIAR-CURRY CUNNINGHAM
LAURA GRAY IRWIN JONES SAWYER
HERE LEVINE FEARFUL ROTH HERE'S
WHAT WE HAVE A FARM THANK YOU
MADAM SECRETARY. AND SO WITH
THAT- OPERATOR IF WE COULD PUT
THE PHONE LINES IS WE HAVE TO
WITH THEIR DOES FRIEND SUPPORT
OF S. B. FOUR FIFTY THREE. KEEP
ALL FINES ARE OPEN. OUR
WITNESSES WITH US- MR HIGGS SIR
BAINES. YEAH YEAH. MR AGAIN
WOULD YOU LIKE TO LEARN HEAR ME
BECAUSE YES WE CAN IF IT WILL
GET SOME OF THIS- HAGENS AND
FOLLOWED BY MISSPENT. THANK
YOU. CAN YOU HEAR ME OK YES.
BUT I'M ON DIRECT RECOUNT THE
STATE UNIVERSITY BY SECURITY
RESEARCHER HERE- THE BRI IT'S
AN HONOR TO GIVE CUSTOMERS THE
SENATE HOUSE ON BILL FOR PART
THREE TODAY. YOUR AUGUST TWO.
IN TWO THOUSAND SEVEN ABOUT OF
A PRO FIFTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS OUR FOCUS IS ON
RESEARCH EDUCATION AND TRAINING
WITH QUALITY JENNINGS BARGES
BUCKCHERRY ON FUNGI. THE B. ARE
ALL UNIQUE BECAUSE WE WORK ON
PROVISIONS PLANS OF LARGE AND
OTHER CONTENT INCLUDING PEOPLE
BODIES WERE NOT A OPPOSITE AND
ALSO WE WORK FOOD BORNE
DISEASES. COOPER COSTS RIPPLE
SIX MILLION IN THE HOW SHE DOES
OVER A HUNDRED FIFTY NINE
DOLLARS OF FUNDING HAVE BEEN
OBTAINED BECAUSE OF THE R. I.
CAPABILITIES. B. R. I. PROVIDE
JUST CONCERT ENVIRONMENT FOR
WORK ON HIGH CONCEPT PROPERTY
THANKS SELECT AGENTS THAT HAVE
THE POTENTIAL FOR DEVELOPMENT
OF BIOLOGICAL WEAPONS WILL BE
USED BY BY A TERRORIST. B. R.
I. IS THE FIRST NON FEDERAL
FACILITY EVER APPROVED FOR WILL
COUNTY CIRCUIT APPLICANTS ONE
THREE GROWN WHEAT CROP. THAT
COULD HAVE DEVASTATING EFFECTS
ON AGRICULTURE. IF INTRODUCED
INTO THE UNITED STATES. SO
PROBABLY TO NO THE- CAN WITHOUT
WARNING. READ RAPIDLY ON A
GLOBAL SCALE WITH DEVASTATING
CONSEQUENCES. FIFTEEN THE
BIPARTISAN BLUE RIBBON STUDY
PANEL ON BIODEFENSE. THE US
BLACK LEADERSHIP A STRATEGIC
PLAN UNDER DEDICATED BUDGET
REQUEST BIOLOGICAL THREATS TO
U. S. AGRICULTURE. LAST WEEK I
HEARD THAT THE CDC PRINCIPAL
DEPUTY DIRECTOR REPORTED THAT
THE US IS NO BETTER ALL SHOULD
ANOTHER PANDEMIC COMMITTEE ON
IT WAS PRIOR TO CORONAVIRUS.
WITH APPROPRIATE SUPPORT
STOPPING RESEARCH IS A
UNIVERSITY BASED HIGH
CONTAINMENT FACILITY CAN
QUICKLY RESPOND TO UNEXPECTED
BIOLOGICAL THREATS. WITHIN DAYS
OF US OBTAINING THE VIRUS WE
WERE CONDUCTING RESEARCH ON
SALTCOATS EACH YEAR WE WERE THE
FIRST TO DEMONSTRATE THAT SOFT
COULD BE TO COULD NOT BE SPENT
MUCH SKATERS ARE FINDING IT WAS
TRANSLATED INTO EIGHTEEN
LANGUAGES STARTED IN A HOLLOW
OVER A HUNDRED OF THE SIX
HUNDRED. NEWS OUTLETS IN FORTY
TWO COUNTRIES. WHAT COULD BE
OUR OFFERING PROVIDE KNOWLEDGE
UNDER. OF A MOTION. UNSUPPORTED
SB OF COUNTERMEASURES SUCH AS
DIAGNOSTICS ON BOXING BUT ALL
CRITICAL FOR IMPROVE
PREPAREDNESS TO DETECT
UNRESPONSIVE. EMERGING PAPA.
BUT YOU EXACTLY CULTURE OUR
ECONOMY AND PEOPLE. ALTHOUGH TO
BUILD ON OFFER. WE REALLY
CANNOT AFFORD NOT TO HAVE SUCH
FACILITIES DR CLOSE MY- THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MISTER HICKS- IS
PAINS IF YOU ARE READY FOR
TODAY WE ARE READY FOR TEST
MONEY WHEN YOUR. SURE SO GOOD
AFTERNOON HONORABLE COMMITTEE I
AM DOCTOR JUST MEETING I AM A
FAMILY MEDICINE PHYSICIAN
LOCATED IN BAKERSFIELD
CALIFORNIA- I'VE BEEN WORKING
AGAINST PANDEMIC FOR OVER THE
PAST YEAR- FOR THE PAST YEAR IT.
PROBABLY BEEN ONE OF THE WORST
YEARS OF MY LIFE AT THE
POSITION- MANY LESSONS WERE
LEARNED AND THEY WERE SADLY
LEARNED IN A VERY SAD AND WORST
WAY POSSIBLE. AS AMERICA BEGIN
TO START TO REOPEN CAN GRASP
THE REALITY OF LOSING OVER SIX
HUNDRED THOUSAND. FROM CODE
NINETEEN THIS PANDEMIC AND IT
STRETCHED BECOME CLEARING CLEAR
DALY- NOW IS THE TIME THAT WE
NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT WE LEARN
FROM OUR MISTAKES AND ANALYZE
CRUCIALLY HOW WE CAN BEST BE
PERSONAL. IN ADDITION TO CO IN
NINETEEN IN THE CENTRAL VLLEY
VALLEY FEVER IS VERY MUCH
APPARENTLY I HAD SEVERAL
PATIENTS THAT SUFFER FROM
VALLEY FEVER AND I TREATED
OFTEN. AND ACTUALLY PUBLISHED
QUITE A FEW PAPERS ON MY BELLY
P. HER RESEARCH AND HAVE ALWAYS
ASKED FOR GREATER RESEARCH AND
VISIBILITY ON THE FACT THAT
MANY PEOPLE INCLUDING
FARMWORKERS- AND EVEN YOU KNOW
KIDS SCHOOL KIDS COME DOWN
VALLEY FEVER AND IT'S A VERY
DEVASTATING TO BE. VALLEY FEVER
COBIT NINETEEN THIS PANDEMIC
ARE ALL EXAMPLES OF HOW WE NEED
TO BETTER STRENGTH IN OUR
RESEARCH AND ANALYZE.
EVERYTHING THAT WE'VE GONE
THROUGH THE PAST YEAR AND
BECOME STRONGER STRONGER AND
MORE PREPARED FOR FUTURE
PANDEMICS. ARE EPIDEMIC THAT
CAN BE ON THE RIGHT. THANK YOU
BANDS WE- YOUR- AT THIS TIME-
THERE IS NO REGISTERED
OPPOSITION TO S. B. FOUR FIVE
THREE SO- OPERATOR THE MOVE TO
PUBLIC COMMENT IF. THERE ARE
ANY MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
WISHING TO. PROVIDE COMMENTS
NOW'S THE TIME TO DO SO IS
THERE ANYONE THE LINE. OPERATOR
THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO MAKE A
COMMENT PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME S. B.
FOUR FIVE THREE. BUT WE DO HAVE
ONE COMMENTING HERE TO JUST BE
ONE MOMENT FOR THAT Y. NUMBER
THANK YOU. SB ONE MARMALADE FOR
THAT LINE. PINE SIXTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES HI GOOD
AFTERNOON JENNIFER SNYDER WITH
CAPITAL ADVOCACY ON BEHALF OF
THE BIOTECHNOLOGY INNOVATION
ORGANIZATION NETWORK SUPPORT OF
THE BILL. THANK YOU YOU
ACTUALLY NO FURTHER COMMENTS
THANK YOU AT THIS TIME THANK
YOU OPERATOR AT THIS TIME IF
THERE ARE ANY MEMBERS OF THE
AUDIENCE THAT WOULD LIKE TO
REGISTER THEIR SUPPORT
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL NOW IT'S
TIME TO DO SO. SCENERY GO BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS.
THANK I DON'T THINK WE ARE
DOING THE. YEAH I DON'T THINK
THERE ARE- ANY VIEWING ROOMS
ANY LONGER RIGHT. NOW OKAY YEP
AND SO- SO WITH THAT ANY
MEMBERS FROM MEMBERS OF- ANY
WITH- DO DO ANY MEMBERS OF THIS
MAY HAVE ANY QUESTIONS THE
AUTHOR. C. NONE OF. MOVE THE
BILL HAVE A MOTION BY- SAID
WOMEN'S SAGGY CURRY AND SECOND
BY VICE CHAIR MATHIS. TO
AUTHORS OFF OKAY VICE CHAIR
MATHIS IS LIKE TO BE ADDED AS A
CO AUTHOR OF THIS MEASURE FOR
THE RECORD. AND SO WITH THE-
MOTION AND A SECOND MAN
SECRETARY CAN YOU PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL- YEAH I'LL TAKE ALL
RIGHT THIS AMERICAN CIVIL
FANTASTIC. DESPERATE THE MOTION
IS A MOTION ON SB FOUR FIFTY
THREE DUE TO PASS TO HIGHER
EDUCATION COMMITTEE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RIVAS HI RIVAS I ABOUT
THIS- MATHIS AYE AGUIAR-CURRY
AGUIAR-CURRY AYE CUNNINGHAM
FLORA GREAT- IRWIN- IRWIN AYE
JONES SAWYER. JONES SAWYER AYE
LEVINE. LEVINE IDEA PROGRAM. BE
ABLE TO DRAW I WOULD. WOOD I.
IT HAS EIGHT BOTH DOES NOT A
BILL OUT- WILL MOVE ON TO THE
NEXT- ITEM IN THE FILE ORDER
WHICH IS FILE ITEM THREE I
KNOW. ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
PATTERSON YOU'LL BE PRESENTING
THAT AS WELL SENATE BILL SEVEN
OH THREE. THANK. MOTION BY-
MEISTER MATHIS. STONE SB SEVEN
OH THREE ON BEHALF OF CENTER
HER TADO ENSURES THAT ALL
CALIFORNIA LABORATORIES
PERFORMING TESTS FOR SPECIFIED
THAT RISK FOR DISEASES OR
CONDITIONS IN ANIMALS AND THEIR
PRODUCTS ARE MEETING STANDARDS
SET BY THE STATE'S DEPARTMENT
OF FOOD AND AGRICULTURE CDFA
CALIFORNIA'S ROBUST POULTRY AND
LIVESTOCK. PRODUCING INDUSTRY
GENERATES EIGHT POINT THREE
FIVE BILLION IN ANNUAL INCOME
EMPLOYEES ONE MILLION PEOPLE
THE OUTBREAK OF A FOREIGN
ANIMAL DISEASE IN OUR STATE
COULD TRIGGER COSTLY RECALLS.
AND DANGER CONSUMER HEALTH AND
THREATEN FOOD SAFETY CHIANG
CURRENTLY THERE IS NO EXISTING
STATE LAW THAT AUTHORIZES CDFA
OVERSIGHT AND CERTIFICATION.
THE LABORATORIES ANALYZING
CALIFORNIA POULTRY AND
LIVESTOCK SAMPLES FOR THE
PURPOSE OF DETECTING CONDITIONS
THAT WOULD TRIGGER STATE
RESPONSE BROTHER THERE'S NO
REQUIREMENT THAT SUCH LABS HERE
TO REGULATIONS. PRESENT
EXISTING STATE RUN LABORATORIES
WITH THE SAME OBJECTIVE SB
SEVEN OH THREE ADDRESSES THE
SHORTCOMINGS OF EXISTING LAW BY
GRANTING CDFA THE AUTHORITY TO
ENFORCE STANDARDS TO REGULATE
THE OPPORT OPERATION UP AND
VERIFY THE RESULTS COMING FROM
THE LABS TESTING POULTRY
LIVESTOCK. FEEDS FROM LAB
SEEKING CDFA CERTIFICATE WILL
OFFSET THE COST OF IMPLEMENTING
THESE NEW REGULATIONS AND
POTENTIALLY SAVE CALIFORNIA
FROM FUTURE FINANCIAL LOSS AS A
RESULT. RIVAS AMENDMENTS TO THE
BILL ENSURE THAT LABS ALREADY
APPROVED CERTIFIED OR
ACCREDITED BY THE STATE OR
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO PROVIDE
THE TYPE OF SERVICES DESCRIBED
HERE ARE NOT CAPTURED WITHIN
THE SCOPE OF THIS BILL. SB
SEVEN OH THREE IS A
STRAIGHTFORWARD MEASURE SEEKS
TO ENSURE ALL CALIFORNIA
LABORATORIES TESTING POULTRY
LIVESTOCK. REPORT INDICES IS
PROVIDE EQUALLY RELIABLE
RESULTS. AGAIN BY A TELEPHONE
THE TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT WE
HAVE BILL MATTERS PRESIDENT OF
CALIFORNIA POULTRY FEDERATION.
THANK YOU SOME REMEMBERED
OPERATOR IF- WE CAN. MAKE SURE
THAT- WE CONNECT MR MATTIS WHO
AGAIN WILL BE PROVIDING TESTING
YOUR LINE IS OPEN IN SUPPORT OF
AB SEVEN OH THREE MISTER
MEADOWS ARE YOU WITH US. YES
THANK YOU CHAIRMAN READ IT
THANK YOU AT THE MOMENT
PATTERSON CAN YOU HEAR ME YES
WE CAN. OKAY I- THE CALIFORNIA
POULTRY FEDERATION ON THE
PRESIDENT AND- WE APPLAUD WHAT
THE LEGISLATION. IT PROVIDES
LABORATORIES ENGAGED IN CERTAIN
DIAGNOSTIC SERVICES WILL BE
HELD A HIGH QUALITY STANDARD
WHICH IS VERY IMPORTANT TO OUR
INDUSTRY AND LIVESTOCK IN
GENERAL VETERINARIANS AND
ANIMAL OWNERS DEPEND ON%
ACCURATE LABORATORY RESULTS TO
MAKE ANIMAL HEALTH DECISIONS.
AND WITH NO GOOD BUSINESS
RESULTS BOB THIS STATE OR
FEDERAL DISEASE CONTROL
EFFORTS. OR HOW FAR REACHING
TRADE IMPACT ACCURACY IS EVEN
MORE CRITICAL. IT ALSO THIS
PROPOSAL WILL REDUCE
REDUNDANCIES FOR COSTS AND
COSTS FOR LABORATORY RETESTING
AT THE AUTHORIZED CDFA TO
PROMULGATE REGULATIONS ON.
LABORATORY CERTIFICATION
REQUIREMENTS. BUT CALIFORNIA
FEDERATION IS ALSO HOME THE
NASA POULTRY IMPROVEMENT PLAN
AND OUR OFFICE CERTIFIES HOLD
CREATED CAN'T BE SHIPPED ACROSS
STATE LINES AND THROUGHOUT THE
WORLD SAFELY AND WITHOUT
DISEASE'S. STRONGHOLD THREE
LABORATORIES AND OTHER
LIVESTOCK LABORATORIES ARE
CENTRAL AND MAINTAINING HIGH
QUALITY FOOD SUPPLY WHICH IS
SOMETHING CLIFORNIA MAINTAINED
AND OTHERS HAVE FOLLOWED OUR
LEAD. WE THANK YOU FOR
LISTENING TO THIS AND- OR
CONSIDER THIS PROPOSAL AND WE
ARE JERKS YOUR APPROVAL THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MISTER MATOS-
THIS TIME- THERE ARE NO
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION OF THIS
BILL. ADDS A WILL OPEN IT UP TO
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT TO THE FIRST WE
HAVE MEMBERS OF THE AUDIENCE I
WOULD LIKE TO REGISTER THEIR
SUPPORT OPPOSITION FOR THIS
BILL. C. NINE WE WILL NOW GO TO
THE PHONE LINES OPERATOR TO
HAVE CALLERS IN THE QUEUE TO
REGISTER SUPPORT OPPOSITION FOR
THIS BILL. THANK YOU IF YOU
WISH TO MAKE A COMMENT ON SB
SEVEN OH THREE PLEASE PRESS ONE
AT TEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. I DO
HAVE TWO COMMENTS THANK YOU
IT'LL JUST BE ONE MOMENT FOR
THE FIRST COMMENT. NINE SEVENTY
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS THIS IS
CHRISTINA TO CARL REPRESENTING
THE CALIFORNIA VETERINARY
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR COMMENT.
OPERATOR NEXT CALLER THANK YOU
ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU RIGHT
SEVENTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
COMPLEMENT PATTERSON ON BEHALF
OF CENTER HER TADO THIS IS
MICHAEL LINE CALLING IN SUPPRT
FROM CALIFORNIA DAIRY INSTITUTE
THANK YOU. ARE YOU I HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENT THANK YOU AT
THIS TIME. THANK YOU OPERATOR-
THIS TIME I WILL BE BACK THIS
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS.
QUESTIONS LIKE TO BE ADDED AS
A- CO ON THIS ONE AS WELL
PLEASE. OKAY SO WE HAVE A
MOTION BY VICE CHAIR MATH IS A
SECOND BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
AGUILAR CURRY MISTER PASS IT
WOULD YOU. LIKE TO CLOSE THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY PRESENT
ON BEHALF OF THE SENATOR HER
TITLE SHE ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
AND TESTING THANK YOU AND MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ON S. THREE SEVEN OH THREE HER
TADO MOTION DO PASSED TO
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RIVAS HI RIVAS AYE
MATHIS. MATHIS I EVERY
AGUIAR-CURRY. AGUIAR-CURRY I
CUNNINGHAM LARA GREAT. GRAY
EYES- ONE- AYE JONES SAWYER.
FROM SAWYER I LIVING. LEVINE
IDEA FOOD LAW FOOD WHILE I
WOULD. WOOD I. WHAT THAT TELLS
NINE VOTE HI THE BILLS OUT
ASSEMBLY MEMBER THANK YOU
MEMBERS. OKAY AND- BEFORE WE
GET TO FILE ITEM ONE WHICH IS-
SENATE BILL FIVE FOUR SEVEN-
SENATOR GLAZER IF- WE COULD
GET. A MOTION AND A SECOND FOR
THE CONSENT CALENDAR THERE TWO
BILLS ON CONSENT. OKAY WE HAVE
A MOTION BY MOISTURE MATHIS THE
SECOND BY SOME REMEMBER I GOT
CREE. AND IN THE END OF TWO
BILLS ON CONSNT ARE SENATE
BILL- FIVE SEVEN FOUR LAYERED
AND SENATE BILL EIGHT FIFTEEN
WHICH IS A COMMITTEE ON
AGRICULTURE- BILL. ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RIVAS HI RIVAS HI
MATHIS. MATHIS AYE
AGUIAR-CURRY. AGUIAR-CURRY AYE
CUNNINGHAM LARA GREAT. THREE I-
ONE. IRWIN AYE JONES SAWYER
JONES SAWYER AYE LEVINE LEVINE
IDEA PUT OFF THEIR FOOD WHILE I
WOULD. WHAT ARE NOT HAS NINE
VOTES GREAT THANK YOU MA'AM
SECRETARY SO GOING BACK TO THE
GYM TO FILE ITEM ONE SENATOR
GLAZERS REPRESENTING SENATE
BILL. FIVE FORTY SEVEN CENTER
GLAZER WELCOME TO. ASSEMBLY
AGRICULTURE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MR CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY
PRESENT. FIVE FOUR SEVEN TODAY
I WANT TO THANK GOD. MY CO
AUTHOR REMEMBER YOUR COMMITTEE
MS AGUIAR-CURRY FOR HER SUPPORT
ON THIS BILL- IN SHORT THIS
BILL WOULD GIVE CALIFORNIA A
WORLD CLASS VETERINARY
EMERGENCY TEAM TO HELP THE
STATE PREPARE FOR DISASTERS AND
RESPOND TO THEM. SAVING THE
LIVES OF DOMESTIC ANIMALS AND
LIVESTOCK IS A WORTHY MISSION
IN AND OF ITSELF. BUT THIS BILL
IS ABOUT MORE THAN JUST THAT.
FIRST RESPONDERS KNOW THAT
PEOPLE WITH ANIMALS ARE LESS
LIKELY TO EVACUATE IN A
DISASTER. UNLESS THEY BELIEVE
THAT THEIR ANIMALS WILL BE
SAFE. THIS PUTS THE RESIDENTS
IN GREAT DANGER. AND IT MAKES
THE JOB OF FIRST RESPONDERS
TOUGHER AS PEOPLE. REMAIN
BEHIND FIRE LINES. THAT
OTHERWISE IN HARM'S WAY. THE
STATE'S PROGRAM FOR- EVACUATING
AND CARING FOR ANIMALS. IN
DISASTERS IS KNOWN AS CARES AND
HAS. STRUGGLED FOR AT LEAST THE
LAST DECADE AT TIMES IT HAS
SIMPLY BEEN OVERWHELMED. TO
THEIR CREDIT THE NEW SOME
ADMINISTRATION AND THE
LEADERSHIP OF THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF FOOD AND AG. HAVE
ADDED MORE RESOURCES AND FOCUS
TO THE PROGRAM BUT GAPS STILL
REMAIN. TWICE IN THE PAST FIVE
YEARS CALIFORNIA HAS HAD TO
CALL ON A VETERINARY EMERGENCY
TEAM. FROM TEXAS A AND M.
UNIVERSITY TO HELP CARE FOR OUR
ANIMALS. WE WERE LUCKY TO HAVE
THEIR AID. BUT CALIFORNIA CAN
AND SHOULD FIELD ITS OWN MOBILE
VETERINARY TEAM CAPABLE OF
RESPONDING ANYWHERE IN OUR
STATE. THE UC DAVIS SCHOOL OF
VETERINARY MEDICINE IS KNOWN
AND RESPECTED THROUGHOUT THE
WORLD. IT'S THE PERFECT PLACE
TO HOST. SUCH A VETERINARY
EMERGENCY TEAM DURING HIS THE
DISASTERS THIS TEAM WOULD ROLL
OUT WITH THE MOBILE CLINIC
STAFFED BY VETERINARIANS AND
STUDENTS TO HELP LCAL AGENCIES
THAT REQUEST ASSISTANCE. THE
TEAM WOULD PROVIDE CARE AND
MANAGE THE MANY VOLUNTEER
VETERINARIANS AND OTHERS WHO
ARE EAGER TO HELP DURING THESE
DISASTERS. THEIR WORK WOULD BE
COORDINATED THROUGH A
MEMORANDUM OF UNDERSTANDING
WITH CDFA AND THE OFFICE OF
EMERGENCY SERVICES. TO ENSURE
THAT THE LINES OF AUTHORITY ARE
CLEAR. BETWEEN DISASTERS THE
PROGRAM WOULD CONDUCT RESEARCH
AND TRAINING BOTH THE FUTURE
VETS. AND VOLUNTEERS AROUND THE
STATE THE PROGRAM WOULD ALSO BE
A BOON TO THE SCHOOLS EXISTING
SHELTER MEDICINE PROGRAM AND
WILL BE INCORPORATED INTO
CURRICULUM FOCUSED ON EMERGENCY
MEDICINE. MEMBERS THAT WE HAVE
AS WE HAVE SEEN CALIFORNIA IS
PRONE TO DISASTERS. THE RECENT
WILDFIRES HAVE BEEN
CATASTROPHIC AND ARE GETTING
WORSE. THE FLOODS AND
EARTHQUAKES ARE ALSO
UNFORTUNATELY IN OUR FUTURE WE
NEED TO DO EVERYTHING WE CAN TO
PREPARE. THIS PROGRAM WOULD
PLAY A CRITICAL ROLE IN THAT
PREPARATION AND OUR EVENTUAL
RESPONSE. AM I RESPECTFULLY
APPRECIATE YOUR SUPPORT TODAY.
WITH ME ON THAT TELECONFERENCE
LINES ARE CRISPY THE BALBOA OF
THAT CALIFORNIA PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS AND DR GRANT
MILLER VETERINARIAN. AND LEADER
IN THE FIELD AT THE CALIFORNIA
VETERINARY MEDICINE ASSOCIATION.
AND THANK YOU SENATOR- SHOULD
THE INTRO- OPERATOR IF. WE CAN
CONNECT. OUR TWO WITNESSES-
DENTISTS FIND SUPPORT. THANK
YOU BOTH LINES ARE OPEN TENNIS-
WE I GUESS WE CAN START UP
WITH- MS BOWMAN IF HE'S
AVAILABLE. MISTER CHAIR THANK
YOU SO MUCH FIFTY BELLA ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
PROFESSIONAL FIREFIGHTERS WE'RE
PLEASED TO BE IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL. AND I APPRECIATE THE
COMMENTS OF THE AUTHOR ALSO I
WILL TRY NOT TO REPEAT BUT IT
IS CERTAINLY THE PRIMARY
CONCERN OF MY MEMBERS. IN
RESPONDING. AND SOME OF THOSE
EFFORTS INVOLVED EVACUATION
WARNINGS AND ORDERS WHICH ARE
CRITICAL STEPS TO ENSURE THAT
OUR FIRE CREWS CAN FOCUS ON
PROTECTING PROPERTY AND HEALTH
BUT ALSO THEMSELVES. RATHER
THAN ENGAGING IN DANGEROUS
RESCUE EFFORTS THAT THEY AREN'T
NECESSARILY TRAINED TO AND THE
TEAM- WELL UNCOMPLICATE THESE
COMPLICATED SITUATION BUT
MEMBERS ARE FAILING TO.
EVACUATE DUE TO CONCERN FOR
THEIR LIVESTOCK OR DOMESTIC
ANIMALS ASSEMBLY URGE YOUR AYE
VOTE TODAY THANK YOU. THANK YOU
IS VALID WE APPRECIATE YOUR
TESTIMONY MR GRANT. YOUR
AVAILABLE GOOD AFTERNOON TERRY
YES GOOD AFTERNOON TERRY THAT
THE MEMBERS OF THE ASSEMBLY
AGRICULTURE COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS DR GRANT MILLER AND I'M A
VETERINARIAN AT THE CALIFORNIA
VETERINARY MEDICAL ASSOCIATION.
I SERVICE THE STATE COORDINATOR
OF OUR VETERINARY MEDICAL
RESERVE CORPS. THROUGH NUMEROUS
DEPLOYMENTS TO SOME OF THE
LARGEST YOUR DOCTORS IN
CALIFORNIA STATE HISTORY WE
HAVE BECOME FAMILIAR WITH BOTH
THE STRENGTHS AND WEAKNESSES
THE CALIFORNIA'S ANIMAL
EMERGENCY SYSTEM AND BELIEVE
THAT SB FIVE FORTY SEVEN
REPRESENTS A SIGNIFICANT AND
POSITIVE STEP FORWARD.
DISASTERS BOTH THE CDFA AND UC
DAVIS OUR TRUSTED PARTNERS AN
ANIMAL DISASTER RESPONSE AND
HAVE FOR DECADES WORK
DILIGENTLY TO PROTECT ANIMALS
DURING DISASTERS HOWEVER. THEIR
EFFORTS HAVE BEEN IMPEDED
BECAUSE THE MANDATE THAT THEY
WORK COMMUTER UNFUNDED. BY
SECURING FUNDED IN FUNDING IN
THE GENERAL BUDGET SB FIVE
FORTY SEVEN WILL ALLOW UC DAVIS
TO BARK ON TRAGIC THAT HAVE
BEEN ON HOLD DUE TO LACK OF
RESOURCES. PERHAPS MOST
IMPORTANTLY IT WILL ENABLE UC
DAVIS TO CREATE A BILL ON THE
GROUNDS FIELD RESPONSE TEAM TO
PROVIDE ASSISTANCE DURING
DISASTER RESPONSES. THIS BOOTS
ON THE GROUND SUPPORT CANNOT BE
DUPLICATED WITHIN THE CDFA. DUE
TO LACK OF PRESIDENT PERSONNEL
AND RESOURCES WHICH IS WHY THIS
BILL IS SO IMPORTANT. HAVING A
FIT IF THEY COORDINATE
LOGISTICAL UC DAVIS VETERINARY
EMERGENCY TEAM WORKS IN THE
FIELD WILL BETTER SERVE
CALIFORNIA ANIMALS DURING
DISASTERS. FOR THESE REASONS
AND SEVERAL OTHERS WE ARE
PLEASED WITH THE DIRECTION THAT
THE BILL WILL TAKE OUR STATE
AND SUPPORT THIS EFFORT TO HELP
CALIFORNIA'S ANIMALS. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION OF SB
FIVE FORTY SEVEN AND FOR THE
ASSEMBLY AGRICULTURE COMMITTEE
CONSULTANTS THOROUGH ANALYSIS
OF THIS BILL. WE ENCOURAGE YOUR
AYE VOTE. I THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME. MISTER MILLER- THIS TIME
THERE'S NO REGISTRAR POSITION
TO. SENATE BILL FIVE FOUR SEVEN
SO WILL GO TO- TO PUBLIC
COMMENT- DO WE MEMBERS OF THE
AUDIENCE I WOULD LIKE TO
REGISTER TO SUPPORT OPPOSITION
FOR THIS BILL. SEEN NONE- WE
WILL GO TO THE- PHONE LINES
OPERATED WE HAVE CALLERS IN THE
QUEUE TO REGISTER SUPPORT
OPPOSITION- FOR SENATE BILL
FIVE FOUR SEVEN. THANK YOU IF
YOU WISH JUST COMMENT ON SB
FIVE FOUR SEVEN PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
WE CURRENTLY HAVE TWO COMMENTS
IN QUEUE LINE SIXTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS GOOD AFTERNOON THIS
POLIO- ON BEHALF OF CAL ANIMALS
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL THANK
YOU. THANKS FOR YOUR- THANKS
CALLER THANK YOU I'M SEVENTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS ANTHONY
MONNING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA GREEN IF YOU
DISSOCIATION AND THE PACIFIC
AGRICULTURE ASSOCIATION SUPPORT
THANK YOU. MISTER MOLINA. ANY
OTHER CALLERS MINIMA PRAYER.
THANK YOU I HAVE NO FURTHER
COMMENT THANK YOU AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU MADAM OPERATOR- THIS
TIME BRING IT BACK TO THIS
COMMITTEE THE QUESTIONS. SOME
OF OUR GREAT. THANK YOU AS
CHAIR SENATOR COULD YOU WALK ME
THROUGH JUST REAL QUICKLY WHAT
THE- A FUNCTIONAL DIFFERENCES
ARE HERE BETWEEN THE- UC DAVIS.
STATE THAT- CENTER FOR EQUINE
HEALTH I KNOW THERE'S A LOT OF
ACTIVITIES ARE YOU SHOULD HAVE
THIS THAT- RELATE TO THE CARE
OF- ANIMALS BOTH IN AGRICULTURE
IN HORSE RACING INDUSTRY NOW
YOU'RE- I WAS BRING UP WHAT
WHAT SOUNDS LIKE A VERY.
APPROPRIATE CULTURES DICTION
INDEED IS THIS A HOUSE TOGETHER
UNDER ONE UNIT OR THE SEPARATE
UNITS AND I HEARD SOME
DISCUSSION OF THE FUNDING ISSUE
WHICH I THINK PROBABLY MAKES
SOME SENSE WE ALL KNOW THERE'S
A LOT OF GOOD THINGS THAT.
DON'T GET THE FUNDING THEY NEED
SO IF YOU COULD HELP ME
UNDERSTAND THAT THAT BE GREAT.
AT THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER I
THINK YOU- RIGHTLY ACKNOWLEDGE
REALLY THE- SOME OF THE
WONDERFUL PROGRAMMING AND
EXPERTISE THAT IS AT UC DAVIS
AND A WHOLE. RANGE OF AREAS.
PARTLY IN THE SPACE AND OTHERS.
I WOULD SAY THAT. YET THE
PROGRAM AT THAT EXISTS THERE
TODAY IS WITH VOLUNTEERS. IT
AN THIS IS AN ATTEMPT TO
PROFESSIONALISE IT IF YOU WILL.
AND TO HAVE IT BE MORE OF AN
ESTABLISHED THING WITH- IN
GAUGING FROM THE FACULTY AND
OTHERS- SO IT REALLY IS TRYING
TO ELEVATE THE GOOD WORK THAT
THEY ARE DOING WONDERFUL WORK-
AGAIN IN THIS AREA AND IN
OTHERS- I I'VE I CAN'T SPEAK TO
THE- THE INTERRELATIONSHIP
QUESTION THAT'S PART OF WHAT
YOU'RE ASKING I DON'T KNOW. A
WE TRY NOT TO BE PRESCRIPTIVE
AND PRIVATE PROVIDE THE-
FLEXIBILITY AND HOPEFULLY THE
FUNDING CAN YOU MENTION THAT WE
DO HAVE A BUDGET REQUEST AND-
SAID THAT WITH THAT THAT
PROFESSIONAL LEISING. OF WHAT
WE THINK IS NEEDED CAN HAPPEN
AND THAT'S STILL TO BE
DETERMINED. I APPRECIATE THAT
AND- SIR THAT WE CAN FOLLOW UP
IN A LATER TIME TO COME TO
BETTER. UNDERSTAND THAT
RELATIONSHIP THAT WILL EXIST
AND I APPRECIATE YOU NOT BEING
OVERLY PRESCRIPTIVE. TO OFFER
THAT'S A BAD HABITS OVER
COLLEAGUES OUT HERE AND YOU'RE
CERTAINLY ONE OF THE BETTER
LEGISLATORS- IN THIS BUILDING
APPRECIATE YOUR WORK AND- LOOK
ALL HAPPY TO SUPPORT THE BILL
TODAY AND- LET ME KNOW IF
THERE'S ANYTHING I DO TO BE OF
ASSISTANCE GOING FORWARD. THANK
YOU THANK YOU. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WOULD. YES THANK YOU I THANK
YOU CENTER GLAZER AND I VERY
MUCH APPRECIATE YOU BRINGING
THIS FORWARD. HAVE YOU SEEN
DISASTERS IN MY OWN DISTRICT-
CARE FOR THE ANIMALS AND THE
CHALLENGE OF PEOPLE NOT WANTING
TO EVACUATE IS SIGNIFICANT-
HAVE YOU. ARE YOU LOOKING AT
THIS SAYS- FOR EXAMPLE WELL I
THINK OF- YES HAS. HAS REGION'S
AND THEY HAVE DIFFERENT TEAMS.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE SCOPE OF
THE FIRES THAT WE HAD LAST YEAR
FOR EXAMPLE- WHEN WE HAD FOUR
FIVE COUNTIES THE SAME TIME
FIGHTING THE SAME SIMILAR FIRE-
YEAH I DID AYE AYE WIN TEAM
ISN'T GOING TO DO IT SO I'M
IDEA SO. SO WHAT ARE YOU
LOOKING AT THE PART OF ME
EXAMPLE IS LIKE I WORK WITH THE
CORONER'S OFFICE AND WE'RE PART
OF A REGION. AND SO THERE'S A
MUTUAL AID AGREEMENTS DIFFERENT
REGIONS. BASED ON- NEED IS AT
SUCH AS THAT KIND OF WHAT
YOU'RE IN. OR I'D WE AND-
EDUCATION AND COORDINATION AND
ASSISTANCE- I THINK YOU'RE
RIGHT THAT- ALTHOUGH IT'S
WORRISOME THAT THE SCALE OF
WHAT WE FACE IN OUR STATE AS
YOU MENTIONED- COULD
POTENTIALLY CROSS MANY SO MANY
DIFFERENT AREAS AND- I'M
CERTAINLY NOT TRYING TO SOLVE
THE WHOLE PROBLEM WITH THIS
BILL AND SO I THINK THAT WE'RE
TRYING TO TAKE A- BIG STEP
FORWARD. AND WHAT WE'RE TRYING
TO DO BUT IT IS A AS YOU YOUR
QUESTION NOTES AT THIS THIS THE
SCALE AND SCOPE COULD BE VERY
SIGNIFICANT HERE- BECAUSE OF
THE DISASTERS THAT YOU HAVE IT.
CUTELY FELT IN YOUR AREA. AND I
THINK WE'RE TRYING TO GROW THIS
IN A IN A GOOD WAY BUT IT'S NOT
AS FAST AS MAYBE SOME OF US
WOULD WANT AGAIN ANYTIME YOU
HAVE A BUDGET IMPLICATION HERE.
AND I THINK IT'S THREE MILLION
DOLLARS FOR THIS PARTICULAR
PROGRAM IT'S NOT GOING TO HAVE
THE SCALE THAT WE LIKE BUT I
THINK IT WILL. PROVIDE THE
PROFESSIONALISM THE EDUCATION
THE TRAINING THE ASSISTANCE. OF
TO BE AVAILABLE AND HOPEFULLY
TO GROW IT IS IT'S DEEMED
WORTHY OF GROWTH GREAT GREAT
GREAT THANK YOU NOW THAT'S I
APPRECIATE THAT I'M- HAPPY
SUPPORT THE BILL IF IT GETS OUT
OF COMMITTEE I'D LOVE TO BE
CONSIDERED AS A CO AUTHOR ON.
THANK YOU SO MUCH SIR THANK YOU
SIMILAR WOULD WILL GO TO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER I GOT CREE
THANK YOU SENATOR GLAZERS THIS
IMPORTANT BILL FOR OUR
REGION'S. WILL NEVER FORGET THE
FIRST TIME WE HAD A BIG FIRE
THAT I HAD EXPERIENCED AND- NO
NO NO WHAT TO DO WITH THE
LIVESTOCK AND WHO CAN HELP THEM
OUT SO. AND I ALWAYS MY HEART
WENT OUT TO THE PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS THAT WERE TRYING
TO HELP OUT BUT WEREN'T QUITE
SURE WHERE TO GO AND HOW TO BE
OF ASSISTANCE AND MAKE SENSE
OF- I THINK THIS IS A GREAT
TIME TO BE ABLE TO DEVELOP A
PROGRAM TO ASSIST IN
COORDINATING ALL THOSE PEOPLE
SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
BRINGING AFFORD. THANK. YOU FOR
YOUR LEADERSHIP AND YOUR
PARTNERSHIP. AND WE HAVE A-
MATHIS. THANK YOU MISTER- THE
TO. ACTUALLY TO BE IMPROPER OF
ME TO. MAKE THE TERM DON'T WANT
TO BEAT A DEAD HORSE ON THIS
ONE BUT- MAYBE IT'S TOO SOON
FOR THAT ANALOGY BUT- ANYWAY
I'D APPRECIATE WHAT YOU'RE
DOING HERE I KNOW WELL AFTER
THE FIRE SHE SPECIALLY THIS
LAST YEAR A LOT OF US CAME UP
HERE AND HAD SOME JOINT HEARING
AIDS. IN REGARD TO WHAT COULD
BE. DEAL FROM THE POLICY SIDE.
TO START DOING WITH OUR
LIVESTOCK ISSUES IN GETTING
ANIMALS OUT. IN BUILDING THE
EDUCATION I SEE THAT YOU'VE
TAKEN THAT. AND WORKED VERY
HARD WITH A LOT OF STAKEHOLDERS
TO PUT THIS TOGETHER. I ALSO
KNOW THAT- OUR COLLEAGUE-
ASSEMBLY WOMAN DOLLY HAS A
SIMILAR BILL AS FAR AS
TRAINING- TO GET ALLOW PEOPLE
UP PASSED THE SHUTDOWN BROOCH-
UP IN TO ACTUALLY MOVE THE
ANIMALS OUT. SO I JUST WANNA
MAKE SURE THAT YOU'RE AWARE OF
THAT- AND ARE TALKING WITH HER-
AS THIS GOES FORWARD I THINK
YOU'RE DOING GREAT WORK HERE
AND I'D ALSO LIKE TO BE ADDED
AS A CO AUTHOR IF YOU HAVE ME.
THANK YOU SIR. OKAY AND- WITH
THAT- MISTER CENTER WOULD YOU
LIKE CLOSE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION AND ALSO FOR MANY
OF YOU FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP.
AND- YOUR PERSONAL AND
REPRESENTATIVES STATE THAT YOU
HAD IN THIS WHOLE ISSUE. I KNOW
IT'S BEEN HARD FOR SO MANY. AND
APPRECIATE YOUR CONSIDERATION
YOUR SUPPORT TODAY OF COURSE
AND- THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE.
WE HAVE A MOTION BY BY SURE
MATHIS IS THEIR SECOND. SECOND
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER LEVINE. WITH
THAT MA'AM SECTOR CAN CALL THE
ROLL PLEASE. ON SB FIVE FORTY
SEVEN GLACIER- MOTION AS DO
PASSED A HIGHER EDUCATION
COMMITTEE HAS SOME REMEMBER
RIVAS HI RIVERSIDE MATHIS.
MATHIS AYE AGUIAR-CURRY. I
CUNNINGHAM LAURA GRAY. GREAT I
IRWIN IRWIN AYE JONES SAWYER
JONES SAWYER AYE LEVINE LEVINE
IDEA BLUE CROSS APPROVED LAW I
WOULD. WHAT ARE NOT HAS NINE
THANK YOU MADAM SECRETARY THE
BILL IS OUT THANK YOU CENTER
THANK YOU ALL. WHO ARE THELAST
ITEM ON THE AGENDA IS FILE ITEM
FIVE SENATE BILL TWO NINETY TWO
MY CENTER WILK WHICH WILL BE
PRESENTED BY A COLLEAGUE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER AGUILAR CURRY
MOVE THE BILL. MOTION MUCH OF
MY FAMILY MEMBER GRAY SECOND BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOULD. HEY
THANK YOU- THANK YOU
COLLEAGUES- THIS IS I'M HERE TO
PRESENT THE THAT THAT SPEAK TO
NINETY TWO ON BEHALF OF SENATOR
WILK- BASICALLY WE'RE JUST
TRYING TO FOLLOW UP FROM SB ONE
FIFTY THREE TO CONFORM WITH
THE- MORE SPECIFIC- ISSUES
APPROVED BY THE USDA AND THEIR
I. F. R. AND FINAL RULE. AND I
SIMPLY ASK YOUR VOTE. THANK YOU
FOR- IT- PUT PRESENTATION WILL
MOVE TO THE PHONE LINES WE KNOW
WE HAVE ONE- WITNESS THAT WILL
BE TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT OF
SENATE BILL TWO NINETY TWO
BRETT. BORROW MR ARE MINIMAL
OPERATOR IS THE WITNESS WITH US.
THANK YOU YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
THIS IS BRETT BEAR ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA HIM COUNCIL I'M
HERE TODAY THE SPONSORING IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF SB TWO NINE
TWO WE'VE BEEN WORKING VERY
CLOSELY WITH CDFA TO ENSURE
THAT THE STATE INDUSTRIAL HEMP
CULTIVATION PROGRAM REMAINS AS
CONSISTENT AS POSSIBLE WITH THE
USDA'S PROGRAM. OTHER CHANGES
IN SB TWO NINETY TO REFLECT THE
CHANGES THAT WERE PUT IN PLACE
BY USDA THROUGH THEIR IFR AND
SUBSEQUENT FINAL RULE AFTER THE
PASSAGE OF SB TWENTY ONE FIVE
THREE IN TWENTY NINETEEN I
CALIFORNIA CURRENTLY IS ALMOST
SEVENTEEN THOUSAND ACRES
PLANTED A LICENSE FOR PLANTING
AND WE EXPECT THAT NUMBER TO
GROW EXPONENTIALLY OVER THE
NEXT FEW YEARS. WE WOULD LIKE
TO THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER AG WE
ARE CURRY IN CENTER WILL FOR
THEIR LEADERSHIP IN KEEPING
CALIFORNIA'S HIM- CULTIVATION
PROGRAM OPERATIONAL AND UP TO
DATE AND RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU THE WAS A
BARREL- WITH THAT THERE ARE NO
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION AT THIS
TIME SO OPENED UP TO PUBLIC
COMMENT. DURING MEMBERS THE
AUDIENCE I WOULD LIKE TO
REGISTER THE SUPPORT OPPOSITION
FOR THE BILL C. NONE I WILL GO
TO THE PHONE LINES MADAM
OPERATOR ARE THEIR COLORS IN
THE QUEUE TO PROVIDE- THE
PUBLIC ON. THANK YOU IF YOU
WISH TO MAKE A COMMENT ON S. B.
TWO NINE TWO PLEASE PRESS ONE
AT THE END ZERO AT THIS TIME. I
CURRENTLY HAVE ONE COMMENTING
Q. ONE MOMENT FOR THAT COMMENT.
ONE SEVENTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YES SIR GOOD AFTERNOON THIS
TEAM MEMBERS OF THE AGRICULTURE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS WAYNE OF
RICHMOND LYING THE PRESIDENT OF
THE CALIFORNIA CAMP SOCI ENGINE
AND THE CALIFORNIA HEALTH CARE
FOUNDATION- WE'VE BEEN INVOLVED
WITH RESEARCH AND OTHER.
ACTIVITIES IN THE STATE FROM
THE VERY BEGINNING OF THE HEMP
PROGRAM- I REPRESENT MORE THAN
ONE THOUSAND HEMP FARMERS AND
PROCESSORS IN THE STATE- WHAT
WE GENERALLY SUPPORT THE WORK
DONE BY SENATOR WILL CALL ON
THIS BILL WE WOULD RESPECTFULLY
ASK SPECIFICALLY FOR TO CHANGES
TODAY. TO GARNER OUR FULL
SUPPORT AND THAT WOULD BE
SECTIONS EIGHTY ONE ZERO ZERO-
SIX. SECTIONS A AND B.
REFERRING TO ONE TENTH OF AN
ACRE MINIMUM KIND OF REDUNDANT
SINCE THAT'S PART OF THE
FEDERAL BILL AND SECTIONS BE
REGARDING CLANDESTINE GROWS THE
PURPOSE OF OPPOSING BE- A
CLANDESTINE GROW SECTION IS
BECAUSE WE FEEL THAT WILL BE
USED INAPPROPRIATELY BUT LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES CRITICALLY
ON PEOPLE OF COLOR AND SMALL
FARMERS IN THEIR PURSUIT OF
TRYING TO BUILD A BUSINESS AND
THIS NEW. INDUSTRY WE GENERALLY
SUPPORT MOST OF THE ASPECTS OF
THE BILL WE WANT TO THANK
SENATOR WILL PRODUCE WORK ON
THIS BILL WE'D ALSO LIKE TO
THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER REGULAR
CURRY FOR HER WORK ON EIGHTY
FORTY FIVE HOWEVER SNOPES-
SMOKABLE CAMP BANDS IS A NON
STARTER IT'S THE ONLY WAY HAVE
FARMERS IN THE STATE HAVE BEEN
MAKING. UP MONEY TO STAY AFLOAT
THE REGISTRATIONS ARE DOWN BY
35% OVERLAND WE KEEP. THE
COMMENTS TO THIS LEGISLATION
PLEASE. YEAH SIR SHOW UP. SO
THE NET EFFECT YOU WITH A THE
TO THE- COMMENTER- WE REPRESENT
THE BULK OF THE HEMP FARMERS IN
THIS STATE. AND WE WOULD STAND
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL AS
WRITTEN IF WE COULD GET SOME
CHANGES TO EIGHT POINT ZERO
SIX- HAS IDENTIFIED PARTICULAR
THE CLANDESTINE GROWS- AGAIN
THANK YOU ALL FOR YOUR WORK AND
THAT ENDS MY COMMENTS TODAY.
THANKS FOR COMMENTS MEMECREATOR
ANY OTHER- CALLERS IN THE QUEUE.
THANK YOU I HAVE NO FURTHER
COMMENT THANK YOU AT THIS TIME
OKAY THANK YOU AT THIS TIME A
BRING IT BACK TO MEMBERS OF
THIS COMMITTEE FOR COMMENTS
QUESTIONS SEEN SEE THAT THIS IS
A MEMBER JONES SAWYER YES I AND
I WENT THANK YOU AND ESPECIALLY
THE AUTHOR REFER TO TICKET IS
ON. WE SHOULD BE IN LINE WITH
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AND-
THAT'S YOU KNOW I'VE BEEN ON
THIS COMMITTEE FOR A WHILE THIS
IS PROBABLY WANTED A FEW
AGRICULTURAL OF ITEMS THAT I'M
PROBABLY MORE FAMILIAR WITH
OTHER TO MISTER WOODS. ABOUT
DID ELSE. AND- AND I ALSO
UNDERSTAND- THE DETRIMENTAL
EFFECT OF CLANDESTINE OR
ILLEGAL GROWS ON ANY INDUSTRY
ESPECIALLY. ONE THAT THANK THE
CALLER WAS MENTIONING AS AFTER
AMERICAN WE SHOULD NOT NO
MATTR WHAT COLOR WE SHOULD NOT
HAVE A LEGAL GROSS AND SO IF I
COULD BE ADD ONS A CO AUTHOR. I
WOULD IF YOU COULD ASK THE
AUTHOR WOULD LOVE TO BE
COLLECTED MORE THAN HAPPY TO
PASS ALONG. THANK YOU. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER. MATHIS IS LIKE TO BE CO
AUTHORS BECAUSE WELL LIKE TO
BECOME AUTHORED AT THE- AND WE
HAD A MOTION. BY SIMPLY MEMBER
A GRAY SECOND BY SOME A MEMBER
WOULD. LIKE TO CLOSE. US
SOMETHING ELSE RIVALED I WILL
MAKE SURE THE OPPOSITION'S
INFORMATION GETS OVER TO THE
AUTHOR ANTACID MUCH APPRECIATED
AND THEN- MADAM SECRETARY COULD
YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ON SB
TWO NINETY TWO WILK OUR MOTION
IS TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER REFRESH. I
RIVERSIDE MATHIS. MATHIS AYE
AGUIAR-CURRY AYE AGUIAR-CURRY
AYE CUNNINGHAM. CUNNINGHAM I.
FLORA. FLORA I AGREE. FOR A AYE
IRWIN IRWIN AYE JONES SAWYER HI
JONES SAWYER AYE LEVINE LEVINE
IDEA PUT OFF THEIR FOOD WHILE I
WOULD. WHAT I FELT LOVE AND-
THE BILL IS UP THANK YOU VERY
MUCH ASSEMBLY MEMBER I OCCUR AT
THIS TIME WE WILL- GO BACK- TO
DO- AT ON BOATS MADAM SECRETARY
WHO WANT TO START WITH THE
CONSENT CALENDAR AND THEN GO
THE FILE FILE. THE FILE ITEM
ORDER THE GREAT. ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR- WHICH WAS SB FIVE
SEVENTY FOUR LAYERED AND SB
EIGHT FIFTEEN COMMITTEE ON
AGRICULTURE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CUNNINGHAM CUNNINGHAM I. FLORA
FLORA HAVE. FIVE FRAZIER.
CATIONS AND MAYBE SORRY BECAUSE
I MEMBER COMING. CUNNINGHAM AYE
FLORA FLORA I THAT HAS ELEVEN
VOTES. HI SB FOUR FOR THREE FOR
TARO DO TIRED CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM I'VE LARA FLORA I
AGREE. HM. ON SB SEVEN OH THREE
OR TWO DO PASTOR COMMITTEE- CAN
CUNNINGHAM I. FLORA LARA I THAT
HAS A LOT VOTE. NOT IS
EVERYTHING. THANK YOU MADAM
SECRETARY AND THAT CONCLUDES
OUR- POLICY COMMITTEE FOR THE
ASSEMBLY. COMMITTEE ON
AGRICULTURE. AS A WERE A STEADY
JOURNEY THANK.